when I was watching this special there's
a chunk of business where I felt you
were attacking me I really thought I
really thought this there's two places
that I went oh [ __ ] I do that with Jerry
and I think I think it's me he's talking
about you talk about all your friends
are annoying but if I go and get new
friends they're gonna be eventually just
as annoying yeah I feel that's what I
feel at this point I'm a friend of yours
yes you are and I must be one of those
annoying people yes you are you are Am I
it's me right yes
aren't you also annoyed by me yeah yeah
we could switch we could get other
friends have annoying things too and
it's the same movies and meals and
holidays and changing all the numbers in
the phone is what makes it not worth
doing the other place I felt you were
addressing me and I've done this with
you and I said oh [ __ ] I've done this
with Jerry you do it a great piece of
business in the new Netflix special
where you go people go out to dinner and
they turn to me and they go oh I went to
a restaurant you knew Jerry would love
this restaurant you Jerry I didn't know
it so much I did that I literally did
this to this guy I told you about a
restaurant I said Oh Jerry I think you
would love it meanwhile you're right and
you're absolutely right I don't [ __ ]
know if you're gonna love it
I really don't what I do we do that the
bit is that for some reason people like
to single out other people for a
restaurant and go you you have to go do
you see why being friendly with you
could be a disaster because it really is
this feeling that like Jerry is
judgmental Jerry yeah no but there's a
paranoia because everything a groove
eights you your comedy especially is
driven by aggravation
comedy is most comedy is and I know that
I get aggravated by everything too but
yes that's why I like hanging out with
you yes every Jew is irritated yeah
that's why I like you that's correct too
by the way
it's not a curse it's your gold mine